[Musique]
surtout aucune réflexion sérieuse n'a
été entamée sur l'avenir de notre modèle
social pour qu'ils deviennent plus juste
et plus durable sans augmentation des
impôts
on ne peut pas sans arrêt parler de
réformes et à chaque fois éviter de les
faire le plan d'urgence c'est bien mais
l'urgence de la réforme c'est mieux oui
monsieur le premier ministre
la fraude aux aides sociales atteint des
montants qui donnent le vertige et qui
exige une réponse extrêmement ferme du
gouvernement
pourtant vous continuez d'être dans le
déni
le nombre de personnes pouvant
bénéficier de prestations sociales est
supérieur au nombre total de la
population française il faut sanctionner
les fraudeurs votre gouvernement doit
cesser de nier la réalité
or vous fait tout le contraire le
scandale qui a fait que pendant six ans
dans le secret le plus absolu le parquet
national financier en dehors de toute
règle procédurale enquêter sur l'ancien
président de la république mais
également enquêté sur plusieurs avocats
dont vous faisiez partie
monsieur le ministre vous qualifier
alors ces méthodes de barbouzes hard en
indiquant que vous alliez déposé plainte
qu'entendez vous faire monsieur le
ministre que pour que plus jamais une
affaire de cette nature ne remette en
cause les institutions de la république
on ne protège pas le droit de propriété
inscrit pourtant l'air en lettres d'or
dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen nous assistons à
une multiplication de faits de barbaries
à l'eau qu'à l'encontre des kids et des
oreilles ou des queues coupées des
entailles au cutter au couteau chevaux
poneys ne sont malheureusement pas
épargné cet ignoble toute atteinte à des
animaux doit être répréhensible et
sévèrement punis c'est d'ailleurs
l'objet de la proposition de loi que le
groupe l'est républicain vient de
déposer
nous demandons nous souhaitons le
durcissement des sanctions pénales à
l'encontre des actes de cruauté pour les
animaux dès son premier jour la crise
sanitaire a engendré des perturbations
considérables des services postaux de
notre pays
jusqu'à suscité un fort mécontentement
des français quant à la distribution du
courrier et des colis de la presse après
plusieurs mois
en ville comme à la campagne le compte
n'y est toujours pas ni sur l'ouverture
des bureaux de poste ni sur la
distribution du courrier et des colis
[Musique]